It's always useful journalistically to
remember the kind of sine curve of a
defeat in victory.
I remember I've just a couple of months
ago,
we ran a cover,
um,
that had,
uh,
three,
four panels and Obama in three of them
is walking across water in radiant
light,
like,
you know,
the great biblical figure.
And in the fourth panel,
he falls in the water.
This was at the nadir of the healthcare
debate.
It looked like he was quite possibly
going to lose.
There was already talk about how
horrible November,
uh,
elections were going to be for the
Democratic Party.
And then he turns it around and he won.
He didn't win a bipartisan victory by
any means.
In fact,
the main politicking had to be within
the Democratic Party to put,
put it over.
But all that said,
he wanted an enormous victory and the
momentum of the presidency changed.
How long that'll last.
Will it have any bearing on what happens
in November?
We'll,
as those reports always say,
we'll wait and see.
Even though that Obama's political
reflex is political personality,
uh,
aims toward conciliation.
It's certainly what made him a political
animal is early as Harvard law school.
It's how he got to be the president of
the law review by drawing in
conservatives as well as liberals,
is how he's succeeded.
He's not a fool.
He sees reality.
He sees the,
the par partisan divisiveness in the
congress.
He wants to win.
This is not some kind of pie eyed
idealist look at the healthcare bill.
That bill can tracked it and it was
shaped over time in ways he may not have
wanted,
but he wanted to win.
He did not want to walk out of there a
gallant loser.
Um,
conciliation is also not a strategy that
will necessarily work with a pretty
stubborn international forces.
Conciliation is not a necessarily a,
um,
uh,
or charm is not something that's going
to work with Mukmood,
Almadina,
Jod,
uh,
or any other,
you know,
any other political force of that.
Like,
um,
there's also a toughness to him.
It's not toughness that's obstreperous
and,
and a swaggering,
but he's capable of it.